Hi, I’m Carrie Anne, and welcome to CrashCourse
Computer Science!
We ended last episode with the 1984 release
of Apple’s Macintosh personal computer.
It was the first computer a regular person
could buy with a graphical user interface
and a mouse to interact with it.
This was a radical evolution from the command
line interfaces found on all other personal
computers of the era.
Instead of having to remember... or guess...
the right commands to type in, a graphical
user interface shows you what functions are
possible.
You just have to look around the screen for
what you want to do.
It’s a “point and click” interface.
All of a sudden, computers were much more
intuitive.
Anybody, not just hobbyists or computer scientists,
could figure things out all by themselves.
INTRO
The Macintosh is credited with taking Graphical
User Interfaces, or GUIs, mainstream, but
in reality they were the result of many decades
of research.
In previous episodes, we discussed some early
interactive graphical applications, like Sketchpad
and Spacewar!, both made in 1962.
But these were one-off programs, and not whole
integrated computing experiences.
Arguably, the true forefather of modern GUIs
was Douglas Engelbart.
Let’s go to the thought bubble!
During World War 2, while Engelbart was stationed
in the Philippines as a radar operator, he
read Vannevar Bush’s article on the Memex.
These ideas inspired him, and when his Navy
service ended, he returned to school, completing
a Ph.D. in 1955 at U.C.
Berkeley.
Heavily involved in the emerging computing
scene, he collected his thoughts in a seminal
1962 report, titled: “Augmenting Human Intellect”.
Engelbart “believed that the complexity
of the problems facing mankind [was] growing
faster than our ability to solve them.
Therefore, finding ways to augment our intellect
would seem to be both a necessary and a desirable
goal."
He saw that computers could be useful beyond
just automation, and be essential interactive
tools for future knowledge workers to tackle
complex problems.
Further inspired by Ivan Sutherland’s recently
demonstrated Sketchpad, Engelbart set out
to make his vision a reality, recruiting a
team to build the oN-Line System.
He recognized that a keyboard alone was insufficient
for the type of applications he was hoping
to enable.
In his words: "We envisioned problem-solvers
using computer-aided working stations to augment
their efforts.
They required the ability to interact with
information displays using some sort of device
to move [a cursor] around the screen."
And in 1964, working with colleague Bill English,
he created the very first computer mouse.
The wire came from the bottom of the device
and looked very much like a rodent and the
nickname stuck.
Thanks thought bubble!
In 1968, Engelbart demonstrated his whole
system at the Fall Joint Computer Conference,
in what’s often referred to as “the mother
of all demos”.
The demo was 90 minutes long and demonstrated
many features of modern computing: bitmapped
graphics, video conferencing, word processing,
and collaborative real-time editing of documents.
There were also precursors to modern GUIs,
like the mouse and multiple windows – although
they couldn’t overlap.
It was way ahead of its time, and like many
products with that label, it ultimately failed,
at least commercially.
But its influence on computer researchers
of the day was huge.
Engelbart was recognized for this watershed
moment in computing with a Turing Award in
1997.
Federal funding started to reduce in the early
1970s, which we discussed two episodes ago.
At that point, many of Engelbart’s team,
including Bill English, left and went to Xerox's
newly formed Palo Alto Research Centre, more
commonly known as Xerox PARC.
It was here that the first true GUI computer
was developed: the Xerox Alto, finished in
1973.
For the computer to be easy to use, it needed
more than just fancy graphics.
It needed to be built around a concept that
people were already familiar with, so they
could immediately recognize how to use the
interface with little or no training.
Xerox’s answer was to treat the 2D screen
like the top of a desk… or desktop.
Just like how you can have many papers laid
out on a desk, a user could have several computer
programs open at once.
Each was contained in their own frame, which
offered a view onto the application – called
a window.
Also like papers on a desk, these windows
could overlap, blocking the items behind them.
And there were desk accessories, like a calculator
and clock, that the user could place on the
screen and move around.
It wasn’t an exact copy of a desktop though.
Instead, it was a metaphor of a desktop.
For this reason, surprisingly, it’s called
the Desktop Metaphor.
There are many ways to design an interface
like this, but the Alto team did it with windows,
icons, menus, and a pointer – what’s called
a WIMP interface.
It’s what most desktop GUIs use today.
It also offered a basic set of widgets, reusable
graphical building blocks...things like buttons,
checkboxes, sliders, and tabs which were also
drawn from real world objects to make them
familiar.
GUI applications are constructed from these
widgets, so let’s try coding a simple example
using this new programming paradigm.
First, we have to tell the operating system
that we need a new window to be created for
our app.
We do this through a GUI API.
We need to specify the name of the window
and also its size.
Let’s say 500 by 500 pixels.
Now, let’s add some widgets – a text box
and a button.
These require a few parameters to create.
First, we need to specify what window they
should appear in, because apps can have multiple
windows.
We also need to specify the default text,
the X and Y location in the window, and a
width and height.
Ok, so now we’ve got something that looks
like a GUI app, but has no functionality.
If you click the “roll” button, nothing
happens.
In previous examples we’ve discussed, the
code pretty much executes from top to bottom.
GUIs, on the other hand, use what’s called
event-driven programming; code can fire at
any btime, and in different orders, in response
to events.
In this case, it’s user driven events, like
clicking on a button, selecting a menu item,
or scrolling a window.
Or if a cat runs across your keyboard, it’s
a bunch of events all at once!
Let’s say that when the user clicks the
“roll” button, we want to randomly generate
a number between 1 and 20, and then show that
value in our text box.
We can write a function that does just that.
We can even get a little fancy and say if
we get the number 20, set the background color
of the window to blood red!
The last thing we need to do is hook this
code up so that it’s triggered each time
our button is clicked.
To do this, we need to specify that our function
“handles” this event for our button, by
adding a line to our initialize function.
The type of event, in this case, is a click
event, and our function is the event handler
for that event.
Now we’re done.
We can click that button all day long, and
each time, our “roll D20” function gets
dispatched and executed.
This is exactly what’s happening behind
the scenes when you press the little bold
button in a text editor, or select shutdown
from a dropdown menu – a function linked
to that event is firing.
Hope I don’t roll a 20. Ahhhh!
Ok, back to the Xerox Alto!
Roughly 2000 Altos were made, and used at
Xerox and given to University labs.
They were never sold commercially.
Instead, the PARC team kept refining the hardware
and software, culminating in the Xerox Star
system, released in 1981.
The Xerox Star extended the desktop metaphor.
Now, files looked like pieces of paper, and
they could be stored in little folders, all
of which could sit on your desktop, or be
put away into digital filing cabinets.
It’s a metaphor that sits ontop of the underlying
file system.
From a user’s perspective, this is a new
level of abstraction!
Xerox, being in the printing machine business,
also advanced text and graphics creation tools.
For example, they introduced the terms: cut,
copy and paste.
This metaphor was drawn from how people dealt
with making edits in documents written on
typewriters.
You’d literally cut text out with scissors,
and then paste it, with glue, into the spot
you wanted in another document.
Then you’d photocopy the page to flatten
it back down into a single layer, making the
change invisible.
Thank goodness for computers!
This manual process was moot with the advent
of word processing software, which existed
on platforms like the Apple II and Commodore
PET.
But Xerox went way beyond the competition
with the idea that whatever you made on the
computer should look exactly like the real
world version, if you printed it out.
They dubbed this What-You-See-Is-What-You-Get
or WYSIWYG.
Unfortunately, like Engelbart’s oN-Line
System, the Xerox Star was ahead of its time.
Sales were sluggish because it had a price
tag equivalent to nearly $200,000 today for
an office setup.
It also didn’t help that the IBM PC launched
that same year, followed by a tsunami of cheap
“IBM Compatible” PC Clones.
But the great ideas that PARC researchers
had been cultivating and building for almost
a decade didn’t go to waste.
In December of 1979, a year and a half before
the Xerox Star shipped, a guy you may have
heard of visited: Steve Jobs.
There’s a lot of lore surrounding this visit,
with many suggesting that Steve Jobs and Apple
stole Xerox’s ideas.
But that simply isn’t true.
In fact, Xerox approached Apple, hoping to
partner with them.
Ultimately, Xerox was able to buy a million
dollar stake in Apple before its highly anticipated
I.P.O. -but it came with an extra provision:
“disclose everything cool going on at Xerox
PARC".
Steve knew they had some of the greatest minds
in computing, but he wasn’t prepared for
what he saw.
There was a demonstration of Xerox’s graphical
user interface, running on a crisp, bitmapped
display, all driven with intuitive mouse input.
Steve “later said, “It was like a veil
being lifted from my eyes.
I could see the future of what computing was
destined to be.”
Steve returned to Apple with his engineering
entourage, and they got to work inventing
new features, like the menu bar and a trash
can to store files to be deleted; it would
even bulge when full - again with the metaphors.
Apple’s first product with a graphical user
interface, and mouse, was the Apple Lisa,
released in 1983.
It was a super advanced machine, with a super
advanced price – almost 25 thousand dollars
today.
That was significantly cheaper than the Xerox
Star, but it turned out to be an equal flop
in the market.
Luckily, Apple had another project up its
sleeve: The Macintosh, released a year later,
in 1984.
It had a price of around 6,000 dollars today
– a quarter of the Lisa’s cost.
And it hit the mark, selling 70,000 units
in the first 100 days.
But after the initial craze, sales started
to falter, and Apple was selling more of its
Apple II computers than Macs.
A big problem was that no one was making software
for this new machine with it’s new radical
interface.
And it got worse.
The competition caught up fast.
Soon, other personal computers had primitive,
but usable graphical user interfaces on computers
a fraction of the cost.
Consumers ate it up, and so did PC software
developers.
With Apple’s finances looking increasingly
dire, and tensions growing with Apple’s
new CEO, John Sculley, Steve Jobs was ousted.
A few months later, Microsoft released Windows
1.0.
It may not have been as pretty as Mac OS,
but it was the first salvo in what would become
a bitter rivalry and near dominance of the
industry by Microsoft.
Within ten years, Microsoft Windows was running
on almost 95% of personal computers.
Initially, fans of Mac OS could rightly claim
superior graphics and ease-of-use.
Those early versions of Windows were all built
on top of DOS, which was never designed to
run GUIs.
But, after Windows 3.1, Microsoft began to
develop a new consumer-oriented OS with upgraded
GUI called Windows 95.
This was a significant rewrite that offered
much more than just polished graphics.
It also had advanced features Mac OS didn’t
have, like program multitasking and protected
memory.
Windows 95 introduced many GUI elements still
seen in Windows versions today, like the Start
menu, taskbar, and Windows Explorer file manager.
Microsoft wasn’t infallible though.
Looking to make the desktop metaphor even
easier and friendlier, it worked on a product
called Microsoft Bob, and it took the idea
of using metaphors to an extreme.
Now you had a whole virtual room on your screen,
with applications embodied as objects that
you could put on tables and shelves.
It even came with a crackling fireplace and
a virtual dog to offer assistance.
And you see those doors on the sides?
Yep, those went to different rooms in your
computer where different applications were
available.
As you might have guessed, it was not a success.
This is a great example of how the user interfaces
we enjoy today are the product of what’s
essentially natural selection.
Whether you’re running Windows, Mac, Linux,
or some other desktop GUI, it’s almost certainly
an evolved version of the WIMP paradigm first
introduced on the Xerox Alto.
Along the way, a lot of bad ideas were tried,
and failed.
Everything had to be invented, tested, refined,
adopted or dropped.
Today, GUIs are everywhere and while they’re
good, they are not always great.
No doubt you’ve experienced design-related
frustrations after downloading an application,
used someone else’s phone, or visited a
website.
And for this reason, computer scientists and
interface designers continue to work hard
to craft computing experiences that are both
easier and more powerful.
Ultimately, working towards Engelbart's vision
of augmenting human intellect.
I’ll see you next week.